zack snyder's zombie heist film army of
the dead is
a lot of fun but it leaves viewers with
a few mysteries
here are some of the biggest unanswered
questions in army of the dead
spoilers ahead like most
zombie movies army of the dead doesn't
go out of its way to explain the science
behind its
undead outbreak that said it does tease
viewers with hints about how it all
happened
we know that zeus the zombie king was
being transported in some sort of
military convoy he escaped when the
convoy got into an accident
outside las vegas and promptly began
wreaking havoc
on sin city yet how exactly he wound up
on that military transport in the first
place
is never addressed before the accident
that kicks off all the exciting events
in the movie
two of the soldiers are speculating
about what they're transporting
revealing that zeus's very existence
must be highly classified the last thing
they consider before
everything goes south is that the us
military has gotten its hands on an
alien
area 51 secret hangar
autopsy it raises the question of
whether zeus's origin is
extraterrestrial maybe not little green
men but more likely some sort of alien
virus
but in the end these are just two guys
bouncing around theories
the truth is anyone's guess since the
movie only dangles this little hint
before jumping into the action
similar to how we don't know where zeus
came from who he was before he became a
zombie or
what caused his transformation in the
first place we also don't know anything
about the military's plans for him
we don't even know what the convoy's
destination was the only clue we have is
that its roots took them by las vegas
what we do know is that none of the
people riding in the caravan had
any idea about what sort of cargo they
were transporting since the only person
who realizes the danger the soldiers are
in after zeus's cage breaks open
is the dispatcher at the other end of
the radio
all right listen carefully gather
whoever can walk or move and get away
from the payload
immediately wait what are you telling me
to do
it seems odd that nobody who knows
what's going on would have accompanied
such precious cargo making us wonder
what was really going on here especially
if the military was developing zombies
as a weapon it feels strange that they
wouldn't send someone who knew
exactly how dangerous zeus was so what
was the purpose of moving him
where was he going what was awaiting him
at his destination
as far as the heist part of the movie
goes army of the dead keeps it simple
and sweet scott ward and his team are
hired by the owner of the casino to
break into his own vault and retrieve
the money inside
yet once they get to the safe it falls
on dieter to break into it because
for some reason tanaka never gave them
the combination
hi my name is dieter and i'm going to
open what cannot be opened
are you kidding me no we need to get to
open the safe
we lose him we got nothing okay sure
this is a heist movie it definitely
needs a thrilling safe cracking scene
and army of the dead delivers on that
but this was tanaka's safe in the first
place so it seems reasonable he would
have known how to get into it
even though it's later revealed that
tanaka never actually cared about the
money and was setting the mission up to
fail
why wouldn't ward have just asked for
the combination tanaka could have at
least given him a fake one
he lied about the non-lethal deterrence
they'd have to get through before
reaching the vault so
he probably never expected them to get
inside in the first place
that it doesn't seem to occur to anyone
on the team that there should have been
a much easier way to get into that safe
even if it proved to not work seems a
little bizarre
midway through army of the dead when
kate laments that her friend guida is
likely dead
lily tells her a story about another guy
she once helped sneak into the city who
got separated from the group he was left
for dead only to stumble back out
three days later still alive he said
that the zombie king zeus had kept him
and a couple other people
imprisoned and returned to take them one
at a time later we see this is exactly
what happened to gida
and even see one of her friends get
dragged out of the room where they're
being kept
what we never learn is the purpose of
this prolonged sort of psychological
torture
if zeus is turning his prisoners into
more alpha zombies
why wait why not turn them all at once
and if that's not what he's doing what's
going on in zombie headquarters
do zombies need to eat fresh meat in
order to keep from desiccating like the
shamblers scattered around the outskirts
of the town
or is there something else going on we
never see what zeus is doing with those
people although it's safe to say that
it's
nothing good unlike the rest of ward's
team
kate doesn't brave the zombie infested
streets of las vegas for money
rather she's there for a friend gira a
single mom who sneaked into the city to
break open a slot machine
and collect enough money to buy freedom
for herself and her kids when gita
doesn't come out of the city with lily
kate takes it upon herself to join her
dad's team and track her down
against all odds she's successful and
unlike most of the other members of
ward's team
the two friends actually make it onto
the escape helicopter intact
however an enraged zeus also manages to
jump onto the helicopter and the ensuing
fight ends with a catastrophic crash in
the nevada desert
just outside the nuclear blast zone kate
is thrown from the wreckage and is
miraculously okay but when she goes to
examine the remains of the helicopter
the only body she finds
at least that we see is peter's who was
killed ward is injured a few yards away
and the zombie king was blown to
smithereens right before the crash but
we never see
gita again did she die in the crash was
kate's entire journey all for nothing
yes she's probably dead but by never
showing her
army of the dead leaves the question
open
just when we thought ward's entire team
had been killed in the disastrous heist
army of the dead reveals that there was
in fact a single survivor
van der rohe the saw-toting philosopher
whom we last saw
locked into the safe by a heroic deter
either dieter didn't lock the safe or
there was some sort of fail-safe on the
inside because
somehow van der rohe is able to emerge
safely after the nuclear blast destroys
the city with several
duffel bags full of cash in tow he walks
out of the city until he finds an
abandoned house with the car and then
drives to the nearest airport where he
charters a plane to fly to mexico
i'm not able to just rent you that plane
[Music]
unfortunately while on board van der
rohe begins feeling ill
and we realize that he's been sporting a
zombie bites this whole time
the film ends before we can see what
happens next but that raises some
questions about how the zombie infection
works
when other characters in the film are
bitten the transformation into a zombie
takes place
mere minutes later yet vandro is able to
travel for hours before he begins to
feel the effects
earlier in the film characters briefly
talk about early symptoms of a zombie
infection which
implies some people don't turn right
away but we never learn more about why
some are able to hold off the
transformation or how long a person can
be infected without realizing it
van deros airplane surprise also raises
the question of whether this means the
zombie virus or
whatever it is is going to spread until
the very end army of the dead doesn't
feel like it leaves much room for a
sequel with ward's entire team dead
and the zombies in las vegas destroyed
in a nuclear blast
now that the zombie virus has hitched a
ride out of vegas is it going to infect
the rest of the world
does the plane manage to land
introducing the virus to a brand new
metropolitan population
the answer to this question feels like
it should be obvious
after all a nuclear bomb was dropped on
the city yet the finality of the
military's las vegas solution is called
into question when van der rohe was
revealed to have survived
if one casino safe was enough to safely
ride out the nuclear strike
it doesn't seem completely out of the
question that others could have sought
similar shelter
granted casino safes aren't like closets
that anyone can simply open up and climb
inside
but it's plausible that other safes
could have been open when the zombie
outbreak started
and were never properly closed or that
terrified casino employees might have
sought refuge in those safes
turned into zombies while inside and
could still be in there
there could even be unknown camps of
survivors hiding out in the vaults
maybe someone hid in a fridge there are
a ton of options
while a nuclear blast doesn't exactly
seem all that survivable
it isn't totally impossible that a few
people zombies or both might have found
a loophole
it seems safe to say that pretty much
everyone in army of the dead would have
been better
off if they'd passed on their ambitious
mission although kate survives the film
and
even manages to come out of it with some
money thanks to her dad she's definitely
worse for wear
after all the only reason she goes into
the city in the first place is to save
her friend and the end of the film
doesn't
give any indication that she's
successful and although it's good that
she's finally able to make amends with
her dad
it comes at the cost of her ultimately
having to put a bullet in his head when
he starts to turn into a zombie
the last we see of cage she's sobbing in
the desert she kneels by her father's
body and a military helicopter flies
overhead chances are that she'll
probably be taken to a quarantine camp
however while her dad gave her enough
money to buy her way out of the camps
along with gita's kids there's no
telling where she'll go after that
especially if gira is dead will kate's
become the guardian of gita's kids
and what will she do when she's bought
their freedom
although kate ends the movie with enough
cash to buy her and gita's kids their
freedom from the quarantine camps
there are plenty of other people in
those camps who won't have that sort of
money
while we don't know a lot about the
quarantine camps what we do know makes
it clear that their inhabitants aren't
free to come and go as they please
in anticipation of the nuclear bomb that
was about to be dropped on las vegas we
know that the camps were being evacuated
but all that does is change their
location not their circumstances or
presumably the guards that treat the
refugees so poorly
you know what's more destructive than a
nuclear bomb
words army of the dead doesn't seem to
imply that there's much of a long-term
plan for the inhabitants of the caps
especially if they don't have a good way
to make money it makes it seem as though
the former inhabitants of las vegas are
simply
doomed to live in the camps indefinitely
which doesn't feel like a very
optimistic ending if
army of the dead ever gets a sequel
here's hoping the camps are finally shut
down and their inhabitants released
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one